on a entendu Gabriel Attal en séance
dire que il avait montré pas de blanche
en quelque sorte avec un document
budgétaire un jaune budgétaire pourquoi
cet effort de l'exécutif pour plus de
transparence ça ne vous suffisait pas ce
qui est bien sûr très loin de ce que
nous avons demandé nous avons donc fait
voter cette récemment là un amendement
au projet de loi de finance qui prévoit
qu'on est régulièrement tous les ans
donc à chaque loi de finance ici au
Sénat mais au Parlement général un
document budgétaire qui retrace
précisément les appels au cabinet de
conseil privé par le structures
publiques disons le gouvernement et ces
agences le document qui nous a été
proposé à l'automne là le fameux jaune
budgétaire qui évoquée en séance
totalement insuffisant il est il est
partiel il est il ne retrace pas du tout
ce que nous avons prévu dans la
proposition de loi que nous avons
d'ailleurs aussi ici voté à l'unanimité
et qui précisait exactement les données
que nous voulions connaître parce que et
on peut pas faire de la transparence à
moitié c'est ça votre rapport dénoncé
effectivement le phénomène tentaculaire
avec une absence de transparence sur le
recours des cabinets de conseils privés
par l'État et effectivement aussi par
les ministères les administrations ce
que le gouvernement proposait ça
n'allait pas dans le sens de plus de
transparence voilà très partiellement
c'est ça partiellement parce que c'était
une globalisation par ministère sans
aucun détail sur les bons de commande
les attributaires il y avait quelques
éléments partiels comme ça de temps en
temps mais absolument pas de d'abord
systématique des commandes de leur
montant de leur objet comme nous l'avons
demandé donc ça c'est une nécessité il
faut que l'État s'en convaincre alors
c'est quoi c'est que il y a toujours pas
la prise de conscience qu'il faut un
grand choc de transparence ou c'est que
l'État a peur de finalement donner la
liste des cabinets de conseils à travers
les réactions du gouvernement lors du
vote de la proposition de loi mais aussi
lors du vote de cet amendement on voit
que le gouvernement ne veut pas faire la
transparence il fait des mesures
proposent des mesures partielles qui
sont des écrans de fumée mais qui ne
répondent pas pas du tout à la
préoccupation du Parlement alors on la
suivi sur antenne Public Sénat vous
aviez mené des auditions rendu un
rapport en mars dernier et donc
effectivement mi-octobre vous avez fait
adopter de façon transpartisanale une
proposition de loi donc le Sénat à
adopté elle est maintenant bloquée dans
le chemin entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale puisqu'il faut que les deux
chambres du Parlement votent cette
proposition de loi pourquoi est-ce qu'on
avance pas du côté des députés ce que
j'observe c'est que le gouvernement ne
l'a pas reprise à son compte il aurait
pu l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour il ne
l'a pas fait le plus de place à l'arbre
du jour c'est un indice supplémentaire
de sa volonté de faire selon ton parler
à l'instant et puis d'autre part il faut
que il se
les groupes politiques de l'Assemblée
saisissent l'occasion d'une niche
parlementaire entre guillemets sachant
que c'est un temps qui va demander un
texte qui va demander quand même un bon
temps d'examen puisqu'à 19 articles et
que nous avons passé à peu près 5 heures
pour le vote ici au Sénat donc il y a
une petite difficulté technique mais moi
j'ai quelques espoirs qu'au printemps
les choses puissent évoluer d'autant que
le sujet des cabinets de conseil
continue à faire la une de l'actualité
en ne basant je voulais vous remontrer
ce communiqué du parquet national
financier c'était il y a deux semaines
le parquet national financier qui dit
avoir ouvert trois enquêtes au total la
première on était déjà au courant c'est
sur les soupçons de fraude fiscale des
mecs qui ne sait que vous aviez
découvert lors de l'audition de
mikeinsay les deux autres c'est plus
inattendu c'est sur les deux campagnes
présidentielles de 2017 et 2022 ça vous
a surpris ce sont des sujets que nous
n'avons pas investiguer cependant je
suis qu'à demi surpris dans la mesure où
nous avons établi un certain nombre de
points d'une part que il y avait des
prestations gratuites de certains
cabinets de conseils
pour la présidence de la République ça
c'était après l'élection mais qui avait
aussi une proximité on a aussi établi
qui avait des commandes quand même
considérables pour l'ensemble des
cabinets de conseils et notamment pour
makinson même si c'est loin d'être la
totalité et nous avions aussi établi il
avait il était appar complètement
pendant nos auditions que certaines
personnes
certains salariés de mackinsey avaient
travaillé à la campagne de Monsieur
Macron ce qui n'est pas interdit à
condition que ça soit sur leur temps
libre évidemment ils n'ont pas pour le
compte de leur entreprise et ce qui fait
craindre ou ce qui ce qui rend suspect
une forme de retour d'ascenseur c'est ça
c'est vous avez des salariés de McKinsey
qui travaillent bénévolement sur la
campagne et ensuite c'est salarié
peuvent avoir des contrats et c'est ça
que sur sa carte nationale
nous nous avons simplement la crainte
cependant évidemment il peut y avoir ce
genre de questionnement et naturel que
la justice se pose la question et donne
la réponse
[Musique]